Harry we have seen that
waise Peters the main
book of Acts then somewhere
comes on the scene and by the time we
get to chapter done becomes a major
player now as we're looking toward the
middle of the book of Acts beginning
with 11 through 13 and there are 13
through 15 we get more and more sense I
think that Paul has become a major
player and one of the things I notice
here and also in Paul's own letters is
the extent to which he has companions
especially in this case Barnabas what do
you make of that in terms of Paul's
ministry or in terms of what Luke is up
to when he writes the book of Acts yeah
clearly by now in chapter 13 Luke is
setting up Paul as a major hero of a the
Christian movement and he's got to be
the focal point of lots of the stories
that going to follow but right it's
recognized feel early on and Luke's
narrative that Paul does not operate
long that he's part of a missionary a
missionary team a missionary effort and
it's interesting that most of the
epistles in the New Testament that we
know to be written by Paul a believed to
have been written by Paul a written by
Paul and someone else right and Paul
will speak in several places in his own
epistles about his collaboration with
other people sometimes with whom he
stands in some tension exactly but he
certainly has close collaborators many
of them listed at the the end of Romans
where he sends his greetings to lots of
people
so yeah Paul was clearly not a solo
practitioner he was part of a team and
the team here that we meet in acts 13 as
Paul and Barnabas on the so-called first
mission right journey right and that
probably reflects some historical
reality Paul in Galatians talks about
how Barnabas separated from error at the
time of the dispute in Antioch after the
apostolic council so for the first phase
of his apostolic activity this fellow
Barnabas probably born from the Diaspora
of a priestly family there from the days
but probably was pretty important in
Paul's life and so Luke I think has that
detail historically correct however much
the the stories of their collaboration
in acts 13 in particular 13 and 14
might be elaborated by up with literary
yeah well I want to come back to those
literary motifs then will my Vista quick
word on the the missionary journeys when
I was but a lad in Baptist sunday-school
one of the things we had to basically
learn was the map of the the
Mediterranean area at that time in
journey one journey to journey three how
far do you think we can count on that as
being historically accurate how far is
that a kind of lucan device I remember
from teaching Luke that we think in the
gospel sometimes it's not so much that
Luke had Jesus itinerary but he has
theological ways to shape the story to
get us from Jerusalem to to Jerusalem
again by way of Galilee right it's
interesting that Luke focuses on Paul's
journeys to the greek-speaking world of
the eastern Mediterranean yeah and
clearly there are things that Paul did
early in his missionary activity that
Luke just ignores Paul talks about these
in in Galatia so this is not a
comprehensive review of all of the
things that Paul did as an early
Christian missionary it is serving some
sort of Luke and purpose and part of the
purpose is to move the story closer and
closer to Rome yeah at which in some
ways is the goal of the whole narrative
arc of Acts beginning in Jerusalem
ending up not quite at the ends of the
earth but in a role yeah yeah that's
right so we're moving in that direction
I think once we get to the so-called
second missionary journey there's a
fairly close correspondence between
where Paul is going and in what order to
what we can reconstruct of his own
journeys from his letters so I think
that by the by the time he's telling
that part of the tale Luke is basing
himself on some sort of good historical
foundation okay and I suspect for this
this first missionary journey Luke must
have some record of Paul's travels to
Cyprus and maybe a southern shore of
Asia Minor it's entirely plausible that
this sort of thing could have happened
but I do think he elaborates question in
this stage sure and then they the
so-called third missionary journey that
we pick up after Acts ad right is
basically a trip to Jew it is it's the
it's
martyrdom story really long way and yeah
there's not so much travel there as
speeches and doctors connected as we'll
see yeah with the Paul's defense you
know but we know that Paul at the end of
his career before he was shipped off to
Rome planned to go to Jerusalem right
yeah that's what he tells us in Romans
yeah and we know why he wanted to do
that that is something that Luke never
tells us exactly yeah we'll come back to
that a little bit later so I think for
the second and third missionary journeys
this good historical foundation for the
first this probably something so what
about among the stories patched together
what about the list first story about
the mistaking our heroes for Paula
Barnabas for being Greek gods right
wondering so this I think is another one
of these for chapter 14 right Paul has
already preached in Antioch of Pisidia
gives a long sermon that maybe we'll
come back to that yeah we will some of
the themes but then in chapter 14 he
goes first of all to Iconium and then
lystra and derbe we're in the world of
lystra and derbe this is like going to I
don't know the backwoods of Kentucky
eastern Arkansas or something this other
Virginia yes this is not Times Square
right right right
and I think Luke is playing on certain
stereotypes about the rustics up country
the year as opposed to what he'll be
playing on when he has Paul go to Adams
in chapter 17 so I think there's a
deliberate parallel as I meant in some
ways Luke is trying to show the Apostles
is reaching all parts of they at the
Roman world all cultural levels Roman
world times and where this this most
emerges is in the reaction to Paul and
Barnabus in in Lystra yeah where they
are taken by the locals who shout out in
the laconian language according to
chapter 14 verse 10 of course doesn't
give us the key according translates
Greek for us thank you but the locals
think that Paul and Barnabas a Greek
gods in Carter
yeah which is of course absurd and I
think everybody who was reading this
with laughs is absurd and say what what
bumpkin
so it's an analogous of the wrote a
story that we talked about last time
it's a little bit of comic relief
between some various serious things so
it probably doesn't write for bumpkins
no the our suspicions from the quality
of his Greek and the way in which he
puts himself at a kind of historical
tradition he sees writing for people
like his friend Theophilus who are
sufficiently sophisticated to be able to
laugh at bumpkins and appreciate
philosophers when we get to Jefferson
right they at least have literary
pretensions at least have literary
pretensions a well-known phenomenon from
that day until now okay talk a little
bit about these these speeches that Paul
gives what strikes me about them is how
freely he interprets the old testament
hebrew scripture as if obviously at all
refers to Jesus and when I teach Bible
study groups and churches or when I
teach seminary classes we spend a lot of
time saying no no when Isaiah said build
a baton shall conceive he didn't really
have the mother Mary in mind and yet
Paul just marches right ahead as if
every verse in the Old Testament points
us straight to Jesus how do you how do
you understand that in terms of Luke's
world and I'd love the dahi understand
in terms of our world right well we see
this phenomenon only in the speech in
acts 13 that that you're thinking about
where Paul is portrayed as citing a
number of verses to make his point and
we'll go and look at those in a minute
or two but it's been with us all the way
through people of citing scriptures left
and right attitude right and they're
they're doing so in in several different
ways some of it is simple sort of if you
will proof testing or reading the Old
Testament with a Christocentric lens and
I think we have to recognize that this
was done pretty widely in the early
church years and some of the the
examples of the being cited here in acts
13 we find in other parts of the New
Testament for instance in acts 13 verse
33 you are my son today I have begotten
you from Sam to Psalm 2:7 it was
originally
a Davidic sin right and it would have
been addressed to the Davidic King was
right I'm just going to be right
understood me and adopted something and
one of the ways in which early
Christians made sense of who Jesus was
was as a son of David right to whom they
royal Psalms could have been addressed
so you can understand the logic behind
and then kind of they're reading this
history of the tradition right and their
assumption that the Word of God is
living inactive and speaks to us this
very day that was a widespread
presumption in the early church around
now there are some other versions of
this we find it let's say in Matthew's
Gospel where there are prophecies that
are fulfilled in our day right that
sounds an awful lot like what we find at
Qumran the sense that almost every
scriptural text is a mirror image or
prophecy about the end time and there
are also in some ways some
straightforward readings of the Hebrew
Bible and in the sense that they're
taken at their literal value and they
used to construct a story of salvation
history we saw that back in Chapter 7
and Stephen Stephen knows a lot of that
yeah
and Stephens speech by the way looks an
awful lot like what we get that's that
same sort of salvation historical
perspective so I think we can see a
number of things going on here in Luke
putting words into Paul's mouth that
reflect the kind of discourses that we
get throughout early Christian and from
Paul in his own letters maybe not
exactly the same way but every bit as
much of Old Testament I want to come
back to salvation history but I want to
do it next time because I think it's an
important theme but I want to get us to
the to the last part of chapter 15 here
which is the so-called Jerusalem Council
many people it is kind of in the middle
of a 28 chapter book
there it is in chapter 15 so that's the
middle but also it's I think it's fairly
crucial it's it's the middle of the
story in terms of what happens there so
let's talk a little bit about before you
do that there's one more point I want to
make about all scripture back there in
13 because I think it's really
interesting oh one of those scriptural
texts that Luke has Paul site yeah is in
acts 13 47
it's from isaiah 49:6 where the divine
voice says i said you know this would be
the the servant of Yahweh said you to be
a light for the Gentiles so that you may
bring salvation to the ends of the earth
this is never a text that Paul himself
cites but I think it very much expresses
what call yourself yeah Luke has this
spot-on put on the mouth of Paul huge it
says Paul self picture is that he will
go to the ends of the earth because the
Gentiles need to get this light so acts
15 you're asking about right counsel
decision yeah it's interesting to
reflect on acts 15 but to do see ahead
you also have to think about Galatians 2
because we have two reports in the New
Testament about what's going on yeah at
the so called council of Jerusalem and
the timeframe is probably the late 40s
48 for the Galleon somewhere and there
Paul has been engaged in missionary
activities some 14 years the core he was
own account in Galatians and the main
issue on the table is can Gentiles be
part of this new Messianic movement
without becoming Jews yeah what do they
need to get circumcised and
interestingly enough this issue was
raised in Galatia not far from the area
where Paul is supposed to evangelize
according to chapter 13 and 14 so Paul's
answer the question is obviously not why
because you have texts like isaiah 49:6
saying unlike we'll go to the job
doesn't say they have to become Jews
early the light will shine on us
Gentiles that was Paul's position yeah
there's neither Jew nor Greek in this
messianic movement right there were
other people who thought this is a
movement that's the fulfillment of the
promises to Israel if you're going to be
a recipient of those promises you have
to be a member of the people of Israel
if so you have to be circumcised that
was the basic debate and some of that
probably associated with James the
brother of James the brother of Jesus so
it is interesting that in acts 15 the
main spokesperson for what comes to be
the apostolic consensus is James the
brother of Jesus who was the leader of
the Jerusalem community and
both he and Peter it's interesting that
Peter does not play the primary role of
Peter plays a supporting role really
Assad they agree that Gentiles do not
have to become circumsized now the one
little bit of discrepancy between what
we hear in Galatians 2 and what we hear
in acts 15 is about the rest of the
agreement yeah and to judge from
Galatians 2 the leading Apostles Peter
James and John and in Jerusalem and Paul
and Barnabas we presume from Antioch all
agreed that Gentiles could come in
without becoming Jews but they didn't
decide what you serve at the potluck
when Gentiles get together after they
Eucharistic service or whatever they do
do you serve ham sandwiches right or do
you serve shrimp cocktail one answer to
that would be yes and the Jews can avoid
it and the Gentiles can eat it other
than say no we ought to be accommodating
and everybody ought to eat the same
thing and so whom do you accommodate how
the Jews of the Gentiles do kashrut laws
apply to this community is the critical
thing Paul obviously that was not
decided in Jerusalem because Peter and
Paul argue about it in Galatians
according to Galatians so what we have
in in Acts is I think Luke's
reconstruction of what came to be a
consensus position in whatever community
he was part of yeah
and in this consensus position there
were certain kinds of food that they
mixed community avoids right you avoid
traif right in effect yeah I and you
will also avoid fornication and right so
the Luke has the core of the story right
I think in terms of history there were
some things that he embellishes and
smooths over to some extent but it is it
is critical on the main point and but
here both Galatians in acts 15 agree
that Gentiles can be part of this
movement quad Gentiles yeah and and
certainly that's the way that history
turns out do you this is your guess work
on my part do you think that there is
that kind of consensus by this time or
you think that's still being
spew 'td we say by this time but by the
top by the by that let's say the 40s
wherever when we're in Jerusalem or do
you think that debate goes on in the
ongoing pall on mission I'm just
oh it's clear it's clear that there's
still debate about that despite the
agreement in Jerusalem it still debate
in the areas of Paul's missionary
activity about how Jewish someone has to
be if you got to be part of this
movement by the time we get to the end
of the first century very much decided
pretty much decide yeah Shirley let's
just say a word about this business of
salvation history which is a word tossed
around a lot when it comes to Luke I
mean we've talked about how Stephens
sermon picks it up
Paul's sermon to pick it up what do we
mean when we talk about salvation
history as a theme in Luke and acts I
think this is a way of referring to
short-handed fashion today the the basic
storyline of the Old Testament and that
is that God established a relationship
with a chosen people and even before
that with all of humankind yeah and that
relationship is one of divine grace that
intends for the salvation of eventually
all the blessing of all of humankind as
Galatians would say but it's done so
through the instrumentality of a chosen
people yeah that's in some ways a basic
plotline of much of the old test you
know and the relationship between God
and that chosen people is one that has
its ups and downs yeah and those ups and
downs and those constant attempts to
restore a relationship form the the
subplot lines of a larger story of
salvation history so what we have in in
Luke is an extension of that story in
some ways all early Christians buy into
and understand themselves as fulfilling
that story although they think the end
is going to be very nice right Luke
thinks not so much not so much but the
story continues yeah and in a way the
church now takes Israel's place and
becomes the the mediating and the middle
community before the whole world
believes again yeah and I think that's
right yeah yeah thank you